so a couple months ago i thought it  would be funny to message guys on dating  app and tell them they have to interview  with my parents before they can meet me  so i said everyone knows we eventually  turn into our parents so i decided to  cut out the chase and just so my mom  interview guys first before meeting if  you're interested shoot me a message so  this guy said how about i grab my dad so  our parents can just interview each  other that way we don't have to talk at  all this guy said i'm interested in  being interviewed by your mom and i feel  my credentials are up to par i said what  if i fall for your mom though instead of  you